[Musique]
si les écologistes se présente
aujourd'hui aux élections
présidentielles c'est au nom d'un projet
qui veut répondre à l'ensemble des
problèmes que se posent les français les
problèmes de la vie quotidienne les
problèmes de la vie économique les
problèmes de la vie internationale
notre projet nous le résumons en cinq
grandes priorités
première priorité protéger la vie la vie
la santé et la nature
deuxième priorité briser la solitude la
solitude dans les zones rurales et la
solitude dans les grandes villes où
chacun se sent comme un numéro anonymes
qui ne parle plus à ses voisins
troisième priorité domestique et
l'économie de mystique à l'économie ça
veut dire consommer mieux et ne pas
toujours produire plus et puis partager
le travail pour résoudre la question du
chômage
quatrième grande priorité développer la
solidarité mondiale pour venir en aide à
toutes les personnes qui sont très
nombreuses dans le monde qui souffrent
de la faim enfin cinquième priorité
créer une véritable démocratie du
quotidien où le citoyen chaque citoyen
peut intervenir sur les questions qui le
concerne
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi de vous
parler de la vie de la protection de la
vie qui demeure pour nous autres
écologistes un point absolument
essentiel et quand on nous dit mais
c'est pas très important tout ça nous
répondons enfin qu'est ce qu'il ya de
plus important que la protection de la
vie et pour en parler
j'ai invité deux personnes d'une
personne qui est connu sur le plan
mondial
une personne qui nous a toujours aidés
j'ai nommé le commandant cousteau le
commandant cousteau qui préside le
comité de soutien à la candidature
écologiste
et puis le journaliste une journaliste
qui vit ici à titre de journaliste
indépendante florence schaal pour nous
aider à conduire le débat concerne la
première question sera très simple il me
semble que la bataille de la pollution
est presque gagné en tout cas tous les
partis politiques l'inscrivent à leur
programme alors pourquoi encore une
candidature écologiste qui parle de la
nature parce que la nature ce n'est pas
uniquement les questions de pollution
quand vous me dites que nous avons gagné
la bataille de la pollution je dirais
dans l'esprit des français oui ils ont
raison c'est vrai mais
tous les français ont en mémoire ce qui
s'est passé avec la bo coca disent tous
les français peuvent lire quand ils
lisent les journaux que il y à une
pollution très préoccupante de l'eau des
nappes phréatiques c'est à dire que
l'agriculture industrielle
malheureusement laisse des nitrates ce
qu'on appelle des nitrates dans l'eau
tout le monde peut voir également
combien dans ce que nous mangeons
il peut y avoir une pollution par les
pesticides ou souvenez-vous récemment de
la sphère du veau aux hormones tout le
monde sait aussi lorsqu'on habite près
d'une centrale nucléaire ou d'une
installation de ce genre là que
quelquefois on vit comme sur un baril de
poudre mais c'est pas simplement ça il
n'y a pas que les pollutions faut bien
se rendre compte que la nature c'est
presque un espèce de grand tout une
grande famille dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons nous aussi et la question la
plus préoccupante peut-être vraiment
celle qui nous fait le plus peur c'est
la disparition progressive du patrimoine
vivant c'est de voir qu'il y a de plus
en plus d'espèces animales et végétales
qui sont menacées de disparition en
france le ministère de l'environnement a
écrit un jour qu'il y en avait près de
40%
c'est énorme imaginez que vous lisiez un
dictionnaire que vous preniez un stylo
que vous barrier comme ça 40% des mots
du dictionnaire va au bout d'un certain
temps
c'est peut-être en profite et fait
parler la langue tout simplement
c'est aussi une préoccupation du
commandant cousteau puisque vous avez
passé une partie de votre vie à vous
élever contre la destruction des espèces
mais ce que j'en ai forcé en quoi la
destruction des espèces
nous sommes aussi importantes pour la
société bien c'est en effet un mes yeux
la question la plus importante après la
surpopulation
il est certain que nous nous battons non
pas pour survivre car rien de plus
triste que de survivre mais pour vivre
dignement et pour vivre une vie
intéressante
or un premier point qui al'air futile
mais qui ne l'est pas avez vous remarqué
l'émerveillement des enfants devant une
abeille devant une fleur devant un brin
d un brin d'herbe
si vous supprimez tout ça qu'est ce qui
leur à avoir du béton des automobiles
des avions c'est ce sera sinistre pour
lui de ne voir que ça or donc ça c'est
un point mais aussi et surtout la
destruction des espèces nous menace
car la pyramide de la vie c'est une
pyramide temps du zoo que pour le sommet
plus cette pyramide est large à la base
plus et les solides et s'ils ont détruit
les espèces à la base les les plantes
les insectes les petits animaux qui
forment cette base de la pyramide en
sautoir est une pyramide très haute où
nous serons en haut mais très étroite et
que le moins la moindre catastrophe peut
balayer et nous donc c'est une question
fondamentale pour survivre et pour vivre
mieux et vous dénoncez aussi la
surexploitation des ressources
naturelles
et pourtant ces ressources qui sont donc
de l'énergie on a besoin pour notre
société
bien sûr on a besoin de ressources et
nous nous sommes tournés vers les
ressources les plus faciles qui sont les
ressources fossiles
les ressources épuisables les
écologistes voudraient qu'on attache
beaucoup plus d'importance aux
ressources inépuisables
c'est à dire aux ressources qui sont
renouvelés par la nature c'est pour nous
une question fondamentale et tout un tas
de facteurs sont en train de remettre ça
en question
mais le principal facteur c'est la
mauvaise gestion aujourd'hui de cette
question des ressources
les dirigeants du monde entier aussi
bien politique qu'industriel créé
économique
quand seulement aux cinq ans ou six ans
qui viennent aux intérêts mesquins des
nations et non pas à l'intérêt de la
planète en général on parle d'avoir par
exemple l'autonomie énergétique pourquoi
pas l'autonomie du café pourquoi pas
l'autonomie des bananes c'est absurde
on peut aussi bien acheter l'énergie à
ceux qui en ont et leur vendre ce que
nous avons et qui n'ont pas il ya là et
il ya un espèce d'égoïsme nationale qui
conduit automatiquement à la mauvaise
gestion des ressources un bruit mais je
crois que il faut vraiment insisté aussi
sur l'extraordinaire gaspillage de notre
beauté parce que par exemple la nature
ce sont aussi les arbres bien eh ben
tous les matins je vais regarder mon
courrier j'ai presque pas de lettre qui
me sont adressées à moi mais alors les
prospectus j'en ai surtout d'ailleurs en
ce moment c'est la campagne électorale
le
nombre d'arbres que chaque candidat
utilise n'est ce pas pour faire toutes
ces affiches qui a partout c'est
invraisemblable
eh bien nous sommes des soldes que le
content que les écologistes là il est
était en accord avec nos idées nous
avons utilisé du papier recyclé et puis
il ya beaucoup d'autres exemples c'est
invraisemblable il n'y a pas longtemps
je n'ai même pas pu rentrer chez moi
parce qu'ils ont remplacé la poignée par
une sonnette électrique alors la soul
est électrique
elles consomment du courant mais moi je
suis très très bien à ouvrir ce n'était
pas un effort extraordinaire
et bien c'est partout pareil de plus en
plus le mode de vie dans lequel nous
nous trouvons c'est un mode de vie qui
jettent qui gaspille qui utilisent à
tort et à travers n'importe quoi le
choix de la première chose est de se
rendre compte promis d'abord que
l'économie de répondre à nos besoins et
nos besoins ils sont pas aussi énorme
qu'il faille y met toute la planète en
perse et bruyants ne pourrait pas aux
besoins vrai bosseur et puis la seconde
chose c'est que l'on change de technique
pourquoi ne pas utiliser l'énergie
solaire à la place du nucléaire
l'énergie solaire ne laisse pas de
déchets l'énergie solaire ce n'est pas
de l'uranium mais cette extraordinaire
les techniques modernes le progrès ce
qu'on peut faire avec la mer commandant
cousteau la mer webber est une source
d'énergie solaire et les puissances
établies nous mentent 1 par exemple
l'énergie solaire qui tombe sur la terre
est équivalente à plus de 160 millions
des usines nucléaires et la partie qu'on
pourrait utiliser de cette énergie
opposants devraient 40 millions lusine
du ter ont même si on en utilise et que
j'aimerais lui 5 pour mille en utilisant
par exemple l'énergie thermique des mers
qui était série clés à la mer le
meilleur concentrateur d'énergie solaire
qui existent par le défaut de l'énergie
solaire c'est qu'il est très répartit la
mer se charge de vous concentrer dans
des zones privilégiées c'est là qu'il
faut aller l'exploiter le vent aussi
concentré énergie solaire dans des
régions précises
tout ça pourrait être organisée de façon
à prendre le relais dans 20 ans ou dans
30 ans d énergie actuelle mais il
n'existe qu'une certaine somme d'argent
disponible pour les investissements et
tout part dans le nucléaire
par conséquent il ne reste rien pour le
salaire et on nous raconte que le
salaire c'est pas possible ce sont des
rêves l'écologiste non ce ne sont pas 10
ce sont des réalités tangibles et savons
qu'il ya une chose qui me frappe dans ce
que vient de dire le commandant cousteau
pourquoi si l'énergie s'est dit solaire
est aussi productrice d'énergie pourquoi
nos chefs d'états qui ne sont quand même
pas des gens idiots et qui sont entourés
de chercheurs ont choisi d'investir à
fonds dans l'énergie nucléaire sûre que
c'est une question que nous sommes nous
même posé et bien la réponse est là ça
c'est triste à dire c'est à cause de la
bombe
tout simplement c'est à cause de
l'influencé extraordinaire des
militaires dans cette société
toute l'histoire du nucléaire toute
l'histoire des centrales nucléaires elle
est liée à l'histoire du nucléaire
militaire
les centrales nucléaires que nous
construisons actuellement en france dit
américaine ce sont des sous marins fin
des moteurs de sous marins atomiques
c'est à dire qu'au départ on a construit
ses centrales nucléaires comme des
moteurs et puis on s'est aperçu qu'on
pouvait faire de l'électricité avec de
même les centrales nucléaires françaises
qu'on proposait auparavant ce d'abord
des usines à plutonium désigne plutonium
pourquoi pour créer le matériau dont on
a besoin pour faire la bombe est ce qui
nous inquiète terriblement aujourd'hui
avec ce développement
de plus en plus grand d'une technique
aussi dangereuse c'est c'est tout c'est
retombé militer à c'est que partout dans
le monde
maintenant tout dictateur si vous voulez
veut son nucléaire parce que avec une
centrale même si c'est pour faire de
l'électricité il peut aussi s'en servir
pour faire la bombe par conséquent je
crois qu'il faut se rendre compte que le
nucléaire est bien il est pollué par le
militaire et c'est très très grave
oui c'est vrai mais il ya aussi d'autres
d'autres raisons
il ya une autre forme qui m'inquiète
aussi autant c'est le terrorisme
nucléaire car il y à déjà aux etats-unis
une certaine quantité d'uranium enrichi
et de plutonium qui ont disparu sans
laisser de traces et s'attaque donc pas
été perdu pour tout le monde et un avis
qui transportait 400 tonnes de minerai
d'uranium vers l'italie a disparu et en
quand on l'a retrouvé plusieurs années
après il avait changé de nom que j'ai
une autre façon et l'ouragan avait
disparu il n'est pas perdu pour tout le
monde et j'ai lu ce matin dans une
nouvelle extravagantes
c'est que le niger a au cours de
plusieurs livraisons déjà livré quatre
cent cinquante tonnes de minerai
d'uranium à la libye bon et la libye
c'est pas tellement pour ses propres
besoins car ses propres besoins sont
contrôlés par les russes qui sont très
pointilleux mais l alibi en fait
profiter ses amis ses alliés politiques
en particulier au pakistan qui fabrique
une bombe
par conséquent nous on a posé la
question aux dictateurs du niger en lui
disant mais ça vous pose pas du problème
euros alors qu'aurel grinch lundi 6 mais
nous sommes en règle avec notre moral
puisque nous exigeons de nos clients qu
est ce conforme au règlement des nations
unies vous pensez comme s'ils avaient
les arrêtera et
il a même ajouté nous pour nous
subissions vital de vendre d'uranium
et si demain le diable me demander de
lui vendre d'uranium
j'ai de lui vendre eh eh bien ce mot
explique toutes les craintes que nous
avons de voir un jour des terroristes
fabriqué comme on sait le faire
aujourd'hui sur une table de cuisine une
bombe avec quelques kilos d'uranium ou
de enrichi ou de plutonium de même
également que le plutonium peut être
utilisé pour imposer des sources doué en
posant nue des villes de plusieurs
millions d'habitants avec quelques
grammes uranium de plutonium mais là
vous parlez du nucléaire et militaire
et c'est une forme de nucléaire
militaire le terroriste parce que le
jour où une bombe terroriste éclatera
new york par exemple eh bien vous pensez
que ça dit planchera d'autres réactions
et le ce sera le feu aux poudres
ensuite garde ou poussés toute cette
chaîne depuis la mine jusqu'à jusqu'à la
bombe suivie en passant par les usines
nucléaires qui me terrorise parce que je
pense que les c'est une nouvelle forme
de danger
nous avons été habitués à des dangers
technique les accidents d'aviation les
accidents de voiture etc mais qui ne
concerne que les gens qui sont concernés
tandis que l'hiver engage dans le risque
les générations qui ne sont pas nés et
qu'ils ont à subir les fautes que nous
ce que nous commettons c'est à dire que
dans mille ans dans 2000 ans dans dix
mille ans les générations supporteront
les erreurs que nous aurions fait en
lâchant dans l'atmosphère dans l'eau ou
dans la nature des quantités
gigantesques de plutonium ont l'art car
le plutonium reste dangereux pour des
dizaines de milliers d'années donc que
ce que vous ne pensez pas qu à vous
parler du nucléaire militaire que
visiblement pour vous et twitter
est ce que vous croyez pas je crois
qu'il ya déjà des rapports qui existent
qui démontre que même si son contrat
c'est le controversé qui démontre que la
sécurité nucléaire peut être rassuré
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas par exemple
privilégié à nucléaire civil entièrement
contrôlée attendez avant avant que avant
que vous nous parlions de sa de ce
contrôle
il ya une chose quand même qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que la l'énergie
nucléaire nous est vendu comme étant
plus propre que le charbon plus propre
que le pétrole etc
donc c'est l'énergie écologique par
excellence naturellement ne parle pas de
la pollution thermique est gigantesque
mais c'est vrai tank a pas d'accident
alors maintenant vous pouvez poser votre
question mais moi ce que je voulais dire
c'est que même s'il n'y a pas si a pas
de faute technique voyez ce qu'on nous
raconte sur l'écologie de du nucléaire
est simplement on oublie cette pollution
thermique qui risquerait chauffer la
planète et faire fondre et qu'à tout la
cia etc alors à dire si c'est pour
répondre à cette question la réponse
c'est non
les écologistes ne veulent pas de
nucléaire il faut il faut de la fermeté
par conséquent nous nous proposons un
plan de consommation et de production
d'énergie et au terme du prochain
septennat si le président de la
république et et écologistes il n'y
aurait plus de centrales nucléaires en
france il y aurait un passage progressif
à des économies d'énergie
et puis à des sources d'énergie
renouvelables il faut un jour choisir il
faut un jour décidé ya pas longtemps
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui travaille
dans une centrale nucléaire à gravelines
et il m'a dit ah ça les deux premières
années c'est magnifique c'est nickel une
centrale nucléaire c'est propre ça
brille c'est magnifique
et puis au bout de deux ans c'est pourri
que il m'a dit c'est l'équipe type qui
met en place à terme c'est pourri c'est
plus droit safu tous les côtés non
centrales nucléaires c'est périmé
par conséquent il faut être clair les
écologistes passeront à d'autres sources
d'énergie vous comprenez il faut des
gens parfaits pour que ça fonctionne
très technique parfaite ça n'existe
nulle part au monde qui peut me dire
comment on va évacuer paris s'il ya un
accident à nogent sur seine qui peut me
dire comment on y va curé nantis ont
construit la centrale du pèlerin c'est
pas possible
moi j'en ai assez de vivre dans un monde
où d'un côté on nous dit que 70% des
cancers sont dus à l'environnement et de
l'autre côté on n'arrête pas de rajouter
des substances cancérigènes à commencer
par le nucléaire un jour il faut arrêter
et s'engager dans une autre direction
d'accor commandant cousteau
oui il faudra faire ça progressivement
mais je suis parfaitement d'accord
d'autant plus que j'ai été récemment il
ya trois ans visiter un hôpital à
houston consacrée aux enfants qui sont
aguerris sable du cancer on m'avait
demandé d'aller les distraire par ce que
ces pauvres gosses étaient isolés et
souffre énormément
la vision est apocalyptique
je suis restée pendant de voir ces
pauvres gosses de 4 ans 5 en hurlant de
douleur avec leur mère pleurant à leurs
cheveux et qu'il y avait aucun espoir
rien à faire ce sont des choses qui vous
bouleverse et qu'on n'oublie jamais et
il a raison brice a raison en disant que
toutes les sources de cancer je crois à
70 % des connexions de l'environnement
aujourd'hui c'est bien oui je crois que
j'avais de manière plus générale c'est
vraiment on ne peut pas le supporter et
il faudrait que nous arrivions à une
nouvelle conception de la santé ce qui
me frappe quand on est quand on écoute
les partis ou les spécialistes que
chaque fois qu'on parle de de santé en
réalité les gens parlent de soins parle
de médicaments parle d'hôpitaux la santé
ça commence par ne pas tomber malade
pour ne pas avoir besoin de chaque
français dépensent 400 mille francs
brossât santé b pourtant les accidents
de la route tue énormément et on a six
ont supprimé de moitié les actions de la
haute l'équivalent d'une semaine de
production il faudrait revenir presque à
une situation à la chinoise vous savez
on payait le médecin quand on n'était
pas malade et puis quand on tombait
malade et bien on ne le paient pas je
crois que en définitive l'écologie c'est
d'abord ça c'est de se rendre compte que
le plus important c'est d'abord la vie
quotidienne la vie quotidienne c'est
d'abord la santé c'est d'abord de
protéger la vie
[Musique]